well you don't think i know what i'm
doing no no i'm not saying that i'm just
i'm saying both of you don't know what
you're doing
[Music]
so i've actually never seen a dar man
video before dar mon darmin apologies to
mr man i've never seen one of your
videos a couple people asked me to react
to this and based on the thumbnail this
looks pretty terrible so let's react to
prosecutor sends innocent black man to
jail so you see your honor it's without
question that this defendant did these
crimes no
that's impossible okay who's the
prosecutor arguing in front of where's
the jury in this and why is the
defendant being allowed to speak at this
point uh
what part of the trial are we in this
doesn't make any sense right off the bat
i wasn't in philly when it happened
i was in la at a dodgers game he's lying
i mean
you know you have a lawyer to talk to
the judge and the jury you're not really
allowed to talk unless you're on the
witness stand as the defendant this is
this is already off the rails we're
we're off to a cracking good start here
you can
tell by looking at him okay well uh so
that's completely improper racism if
there is a jury somewhere in this
courtroom uh that's
probably immediate grounds for a
mistrial you're not allowed to engage in
overt racism
while the trial is going on this is
insane order
defendant do you have any proof of your
alibi
oh now i remember darman i think uh drew
gooden or danny gonzalez or both of them
did a video on this they're videos where
you it's totally unrealistic but you
feel good at the end of the video now i
remember
uh
uh no we don't have any proof your honor
okay okay so
where are we in the trial right now the
judge is just flat asking the defense if
they have evidence there's you know a
whole trial that you go through you call
witnesses you present evidence there are
uh motions at lemonade to admit things
into evidence you don't just ask the
council like do you have any evidence to
support your claim here and
why can't the defense counsel come up
with evidence that this person wasn't
even in the city at the time
okay well if there's no evidence to
corroborate robert's story
that's insane
okay so so you're not in philadelphia
you're in los angeles how did you get
there who did you talk to did you buy
anything did you make a a cell phone
conversation you brought your cell phone
right you have a mobile phone you could
ping a cell tower you probably bought
something you had to have a ticket to
get to los angeles you didn't walk there
this is this is insanity how
there's no possible way that a defense
attorney would be so incompetent as to
have zero evidence at all
excuse me i must use the restroom
and this is the thing that that really
bothers me is that
even if you have a witness and it's just
you know he said she said
that's still considered evidence a
witness testifying is often direct
evidence and it's this what a lot of
people consider the strongest you could
have
my mind is is is reeling it's it's
absolutely a rollercoaster inside my
brain right now uh boy wow
the court finds the defendant robert
williams guilty there's
there's no jury here it's just the judge
he's just
do you have any
do you have any evidence mr defense
counsel no all right guilty
that's not how a criminal trial works i
mean you know this there's a jury you
void you're the jury you present
evidence and then you're in you instruct
the jury
this is
i'm i'm already broken and we're
30 seconds into this video
no
no please please not my baby boy
okay why are we letting people in the
gallery talk
i know we did it all right yeah all
right so there's an outburst
you have to believe me i'm innocent
i put that on my life
you know i didn't do this
you know it order
mr williams that's enough that's not
another word
why would the prosecutor know he didn't
do this
the defense didn't present any evidence
whatsoever
we'll reconvene tomorrow for sentencing
oh yeah sentencing tomorrow yeah courts
are so backlogged especially now
sentencing wouldn't happen for probably
a few weeks i would think
teddy
no please
don't go
everything is gonna be okay sweetie i
promise
daddy loves you so much
what if he's telling the truth
what if we got the wrong guy
yeah we just convicted him what if he's
telling the truth based on absolutely
nothing whatsoever
well you don't think i know what i'm
doing no no i'm not saying that i'm just
i'm saying both of you don't know what
you're doing wondering if maybe we
shouldn't take another look at the facts
i just want a case
who cares whether he did it or not
okay uh prosecutors uh are stereotyped
this way but that's not the philosophy
that they have they want to convict
people that have actually done something
and if someone didn't do that then by
and large every prosecutor i know would
not want to convict that person um
now
granted i guess there was a trial here
that we didn't see and he got a
conviction so there was evidence that
this person did something and presumably
it was evidence beyond a reasonable
doubt but you know still this is not the
time or the place all that's important
is i'm one step closer to a promotion
promotion for what is this guy okay so
this guy must be an assistant district
attorney or deputy district attorney i
mean what what promotion is he angling
for the management position of some kind
oh and also
so you convicted a guy of assault with a
deadly weapon this is as routine as it's
going to get for your sort of mid-level
felony district attorney like that's not
going to help you get a promotion
anywhere
so dumb
and besides
people like him they're all the same
just a bunch of criminals all right
great so we've got some overt racism
well i mean at least we know who the bad
guys are
please
sir please
it's never too late to do the right
thing
i mean
it is sort of too late he was convicted
here
it's it's really hard to undo a
conviction there's not a whole lot that
you can do here but let's uh let's see
[Music]
yeah well i can see my headlines now
d.a graham gives low-life criminal
life in prison
yeah well okay that headline's not going
to happen because he was convicted of
assault with a deadly weapon which does
not carry a life sentence with it and i
think you're already the district
attorney here also no newspaper is going
to run with that story because this
happens a thousand times a day this is
like no one's going to care about this
oh
man so ridiculous
keep up the great work he's innocent
he's innocent
can you give us a minute
yeah
what a
what a dip [ __ ] he's innocent what an
[ __ ]
what are you talking about
he wasn't in philly when it happened his
story checks out look i have his credit
card statements right here he was making
purchases in los angeles while the crime
was happening what do you
what do you mean you have his credit
card statements
if okay okay all right if the district
attorney had this evidence and didn't
turn it over to the defense that is a
brady violation
left right and center that is that is
ridiculous that they wouldn't have
turned that over to the defense
presumably they had to subpoena the
credit card company so they went through
all the rigmarole of getting this
evidence if the prosecutor has
exculpatory evidence you have to turn
that over to the defense so presumably
he had all of this stuff in front of him
he just didn't turn it over to the
defense so this is actually one of those
rare circumstances where the defense
would be probably able to overturn this
conviction so once the defense gets this
evidence uh the defense would then file
a motion with the judge to vacate the
judgment and to dismiss the judgment
with prejudice and then maybe you asked
the court to sanction the prosecutor for
very clear miscarriage of justice but
yeah okay so
that the prosecutors had this from the
very beginning is insanity we have to
get these to the defense right away have
you lost your mind
i mean uh
maybe somebody
stole his card
maybe he gave it to him
yeah so it doesn't matter the prosecutor
doesn't get to come up with alternative
explanations if the evidence is
exculpatory you have to turn it over to
the defense
i can think of a thousand reasons yeah
it doesn't matter how many reasons
that's enough
okay it's
over
you hear me
i have proof
what is it you already had proof now i
contacted a local convenience store and
i found a photo of him take a look
he couldn't have committed a crime in
philly if he was buying a hot dog in l.a
okay so this is a little bit different
this is newly acquired evidence so if
the defense found this evidence and they
wanted to admit it and overturn the
initial conviction they would have had
to have filed a motion for a new trial
and the standard there is that they
wouldn't have been able to discover this
evidence with reasonable diligence
before the trial itself
but
this probably wasn't that hard to find
they probably wouldn't have been able to
meet that standard because this defense
attorney just completely dropped the
ball and said there was absolutely no
evidence at all however since the
prosecution now has it in their
possession it's probably still a brady
violation that they're not turning it
over uh but still they didn't have the
obligation to affirmatively go out and
find this evidence in the first place
that's up to the defense and they
dropped the ball
good neighbor look like him
it's him i had facial recognition
confirm it
what what facial recognition that's
this isn't an episode of csi
has anyone else seen this
no why good
let's keep it that way well someone had
to see it because the district attorney
had to subpoena those records from the
convenience store
what what papers is the defense attorney
reviewing right now like the transcript
where he says no we don't have any
evidence your honor look it's kind of
over and done now we're just at the
sentencing phase
you're not gonna believe this
i have video evidence
what are you talking about well a
reporter was giving an interview outside
of the game
okay so
so guess who walks by
there
that's robert how would he have found
that i mean that's
that's really going above and beyond to
try and find this particular evidence oh
and another thing this is this is the
next day so we're assuming that the
district attorney was somehow able to
subpoena a convenience store and get it
turned around in
like two hours this would have taken
weeks or months and same thing with
finding this video evidence as well
that's
i don't know how many times i've said
that's ridiculous and unrealistic but
it's spin a lot in this video this this
proves
okay
that fountain is nowhere near dodger
stadium i mean that's i guess that's the
los angelino in me but uh i mean that's
also ridiculous his innocence
we have to tell the judge yes you do
have to tell the judge
have a seat
we have to tell the judge you don't have
to tell a soul
yes you do is everything okay you know
in the constitution mr graham
anything you want to share
no your honor very well
mr williams okay
uh another thing maybe this is small in
the grand scheme of things but i would
sue the crap out of the defense attorney
here because i mean this is ineffective
advice of counsel this is this is really
terrible representation not only is he
not finding the evidence that's
laying in front of him uh but he's
completely botched this entire case so
yeah this guy has a great cause of
action against his former attorney
because this guy is the worst federal
statute requires a 25-year mandatory
minimum sentence federal statute
this is state court in in philadelphia
this has nothing to do with federal
courts at all
and 25 years this is this is assault
with a deadly weapon this is okay first
of all in pennsylvania that's a maximum
of 10 years in prison and the reality is
he's gonna get like 70 months so he's in
he's probably convicted for uh
incentives for
less than six years
presuming since this guy is completely
innocent uh it's probably his first
offense so yeah he's at the low end of
the spectrum maybe five to six years in
jail
not 25 years in jail for assault with a
deadly weapon ridiculous
you've already been found guilty
so unless the people have anything else
if only there had been a trial in front
of some sort of jury of your peers where
you could present
evidence but sadly that's not the world
we live in
this court hereby sentences the
defendant robert williams to 25 years in
a federal prison without the possibility
okay a pennsylvania court has no
authority to send you to federal prison
that's not a
[Laughter]
oh
thing
okay
the judge has already made his sentence
like banging the gavel to the extent the
judge ever does that which is not often
it doesn't carry any
specific weight it's not like nothing i
said matters until i smack this wooden
hammer against the table
it's over it's over at this point
[Music]
excuse me
hey i'm sorry your honor he didn't do it
may i approach the bench
you may
your honor there is no way that mr
williams committed those crimes you
don't have to
interrupt the the court and present all
your evidence that's actually probably
sort of improper you'd probably ask to
adjourn this particular sentencing so
that you can talk with the defense so
that everyone can present their motions
but you know
darman get a dharman i guess you see
i have here a credit card statement
showing purchases made by the defendant
with his credit card in los angeles on
the same day that the crime took place
in philadelphia
is there and i also have there's got to
be a chain of custody issues photo
of the defendant
in a convenience store here in los
angeles buying a hot dog
just mere moments before the crime took
place
and i have a video as well your honor
so you see your honor
robert williams could not have committed
those crimes
is uh
is all this true mr graham
well uh why didn't you say anything
because he was more interested in his
promotion than he was in saving an
innocent man from jail again i can't
fathom what promotion he's angling for
here and also like okay you presented
your evidence you don't necessarily need
to throw this guy under the bus and
frankly i think
some of these discussions are probably
privileged um
you know whatever i mean at this point
sure why not
well what'd you expect
huh okay so maybe he didn't do this
crime
but i'm sure he's done dozens of others
you're damn right i ordered the code red
that that does not happen
look at him he's clearly a criminal your
honor order
yeah finally finally the defense objects
to like overt racism oh boy
where have you been buddy
i've heard all i've needed to hear mr
williams
the charges against you have been
dropped you're free to go
bailiff i'm cuffing immediately
okay yeah i mean sure yeah why not and
you uh suspente motion to vacate uh okay
i'll allow it
mr graham oh obstructing justice and
tampering with evidence is a very
serious crime your honor i'm going to
see to it that not only do you never
practice law again
but that we send the right man to jail
this time
you
bailiff
arrest him
okay
this guy may have been
god is that is that obstruction of
justice maybe that might give rise i
mean mainly it's it's just a really
horrible brady violation and uh i don't
know that that necessarily gives rise to
obstruction of justice either way i
don't think the judge has the power to
have the bailiff arrest this guy
you would probably refer him to bar
counsel for sure and maybe you refer to
another prosecutor uh based on the facts
but
yeah i don't i don't think there's any
world in which this guy is arrested
after
a sentencing hearing like this there's
you know you've got to engage in
discovery too
okay i'm done no more
no more
no no this can't be happening yeah it
literally can't be happening
[Applause]
why did you help us
well because a wise woman once told me
it's never too late to do the right
thing
isn't that a 30 rock joke oh no it's
close but you know almost as cringy but
it's cringy on purpose
god it's never too late for now
[Music]
[Music]
that's that's not a newspaper that's uh
it's like uh
one of those fake things that you print
out in like print shop i mean at least
make it big it's it's eight and a half
by eleven
the daily news
[Music]
never too late for now
hey darman fam so you see we're not just
telling stories we're changing lives
okay he knows that this didn't actually
happen
no one's life was changed here
this is a this is a fictional story that
didn't happen in real life no one's no
one
look i'm on youtube too
we're not necessarily changing lives
here we're making things that are
entertaining like slow your roll buddy
and when you share my videos you're
helping to change lives too
i mean come on now now when you share a
legal eagle video of course you're
changing lives uh but a darman video i'm
not sure about that okay let's put me
out of my misery uh let's give this
thing a grade for legal realism
[Music]
on the plus side i guess they use terms
like defendant and district attorney
other than that
kind of nothing on the other side pretty
much everything this is the most
unrealistic thing i've ever seen it's
procedurally and substantively improper
yeah this is the worst fictional account
of a legal proceeding i've ever seen in
my life f
now you might be dumber for having
watched this video but you won't be with
today's sponsor morningbrew i've
actually been subscribed to morningbrew
for forever it's one of my absolute
favorite newsletters and it's awesome
that they wanted to sponsor this channel
morningbrew if you didn't know is a free
daily newsletter delivered monday
through sunday it gets you up to speed
on business finance tech and law in just
five minutes and it provides a fantastic
quick survey of the most important
issues while being witty irreverent and
informative and did i mention it's
completely free and it tells me how much
my stocks are going up and how much
everyone else's crypto is going down
this week for example i learned about
elon musk leaving california for texas
twitch getting hacked the facebook
whistleblower and a vegan shrimp
substitute called vrimp
it's basically exactly the mix of news
that i'm actually interested in and the
stuff i didn't know i wanted to know
about and it's all written in a
hilarious style morning brew is one of
the few emails that i actually open
religiously so league legals this one is
a complete no-brainer morning brew is
completely free and it takes less than
15 seconds to subscribe just click on
the link that's on screen now or in the
description to get morning brew for free
and not only will you get a newsletter
that you'll actually read but you'll
actually be helping out this channel too
so click on the link below to get
morningbrew right away and while you're
at it check out this playlist with all
of my real lawyer reactions so click on
this playlist or i'll see you in court